i'm martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday
august 18 2021
i'm dave anthony the u.s military keeps
helping evacuate americans and some
afghans but what about those who helped
us in the war the taliban won't let get
to the capitol we're going to get only
the people probably out of kabul and
that's going to haunt me for the rest of
my life because there's another 50 000
people outside of kabul that we're going
to leave behind and for me that's the
equivalent of leaving behind someone who
is jewish and not see germany
i'm jessica rosenthal the head of
homeland security admits what's
happening at the border isn't
sustainable as an outgoing border patrol
chief warns of an increase in terror
suspects coming in through mexico i
think that's something that the american
people need to understand that this
isn't just immigration this is about
drugs this is about cartel activity
and this is about national security i'm
liz peake i've got the final word on the
fox news rundown
[Music]
the taliban is back in power setting up
a new afghan government after taking
over while u.s troops pulled out we were
clear-eyed going in when we made this
decision
that it was
possible that the taliban would end up
in control of afghanistan national
security adviser jake sullivan says they
keep evacuating americans and the
taliban have informed us that they are
prepared to provide the safe passage of
civilians to the airport but the taliban
claims all afghans who help the u.s
during the war are forgiven we do not
want them to leave the country we want
them to serve their own homeland taliban
spokesman zubiallah muhajeet also claims
women will be afforded all their rights
whether it is in work or other
activities because women
are a key part of society but many
republicans in congress fear the
taliban's return means al-qaeda and
terrors return gop senator lindsey
graham tells fox news radio he is set in
motion president biden
a pathway to another 911. former
president trump who started the
withdrawal process and wanted us out of
afghanistan told fox's hannity it's not
that we left it's the grossly
incompetent way we left and we talked to
a democrat who agrees it didn't go well
a disaster of epic proportions that was
eminently preventable matt zeller is a
former u.s army major and ex-cia analyst
who co-founded a group several years ago
to help our afghan allies leave called
no one left behind you know i've been
part of a coalition of individuals that
has been spending the better part of the
last
year
desperately trying to get the american
government first the trump
administration and now the biden
administration to plan for what they're
now attempting to pull off which is the
largest humanitarian airlift since 1948
since the berlin airlift we're going to
get only the people probably out of
kabul and that's going to haunt me for
the rest of my life because there's
another 50 000 people outside of kabul
that we're gonna leave behind and for me
that's the equivalent of leaving behind
someone who is jewish and nazi germany
wow this is very personal for you i have
family who are there my sister was there
she i just got confirmation about an
hour before we recorded this that she
was finally put on a plane and she's
flying back to the united states this is
deeply personal how scary was it for you
until you found out that she's gonna be
able to get back
that she would be stuck there
i i've slept three hours in the last 72
i was on the phone at four o'clock this
morning with her at the gate at the
airport to help her talk her way past
the marine guards there and and let them
know that she was an american citizen
thankfully they were more than
professional they were amazing i can't
even begin to imagine the nightmare that
they're dealing with you just have
thousands upon thousands of afghans who
are trying to get to the one airport
that they know is their lifeline to
freedom and safety
in between them is a taliban army that
is now setting up checkpoints we have
gotten
confirmation from multiple sources on
the ground
that the taliban have a checkpoint a
hundred meters from the americans at the
airport and what they're doing is
anybody who shows up that has english in
their phone they're confiscating their
phone
they're telling people that they're
making a list and that they're going to
be back for people once the americans
leave and you believe that's probably
going to happen i know it's already
happening because i also am talking to
people in places that aren't kabul
cities like kandahar and herat in mazari
sharif
and what they're telling me is that
there was already a mass execution
in kandahar in which they made people
come to the stadium to watch people be
publicly beheaded
women have been fired from all of their
jobs everywhere they're not allowed to
work anymore
at least outside of kabul
and they're going door to door looking
for the people who work for us and
unlike in kabul where they're just
making a list of people that they plan
to be back for once we're gone the
people that they're looking for and the
outlying cities are disappearing never
to be seen again
the taliban
in kabul as they're having negotiations
trying to set up a government they're
claiming that
everyone is forgiven
amnesty for all afghans and and they
want to have an inclusive government and
then hey women are welcome
you believe any of that
no i i i have not believed the taliban
since the nanosecond i first laid eyes
on them in 2008 personally these aren't
people who can be trusted
you were there when you were in
afghanistan
you were also with afghan forces correct
you helped train those fighters
i lived on an afghan army base in the
middle of a province called ghazni uh
the people that i spent most of my year
with were afghans i had about 20 other
americans on our little outpost and a
hell of a lot of afghans around us and
let me tell you something i don't blame
them for losing this
these are people
who despite the fact that they were
never paid on time or if ever that they
often didn't have fuel or ammunition or
proper equipment
proper training and despite all of that
they kept showing up to the fight time
and time again
now on monday
president biden as you watched
said that leaders gave up and fled the
country the afghan military collapsed
sometime without trying to fight
and he then said that if anything it
reinforces that ending the us military
involvement now was the right decision
no yes
you know i think ending the war was
absolutely the right decision
shame on us for having a a war that
clearly was unwinnable go on this long
but here's the thing
when you end a war how you end it is
just as important as why the war was
fought
no one
wanted this type of an exit
no one wanted this
so
what
should have happened what would be the
better way to have exited
six months ago it wasn't fighting season
we had all of the 2500 troops in place
it's not too far-fetched to imagine six
months ago starting to send out special
operations teams to remote villages to
helicopter our allies back to these air
bases and then quietly over time
methodically flying them back to the
united states like we are now that's
what should have happened by the way
that still could we just we lack the
political conviction to do the right
thing now we could still go in and
retake these airfields the taliban are
terrified of us they're not going to
risk a return to an all-out war with us
simply because we're trying to evacuate
people that quite frankly they don't
want in their country to begin with back
to president biden on monday the scenes
were seen in afghanistan
they're gut-wrenching but at the same
time he defended the u.s troop
withdrawal i stand squarely behind my
decision as for why they didn't evacuate
afghan allies sooner the president says
the government in kabul discouraged that
fearing a mass exodus would lead to a
crisis in confidence
matt zeller disagrees we wouldn't be
facing this crisis now a crisis is quite
frankly of our own creation because we
refused to do the right thing when we
could have and that is something that i
am going to have to live with for the
rest of my life as a profound failure on
my part because clearly i wasn't
effective enough in getting my
government to pay attention
and that's a moral injury that i now
know all too well what vietnam veterans
felt like
i'm still talking to people in taliban
occupied cities and what they're telling
me is their lives are over
and what i can't
what makes me so emotional
is that to a person they're not angry
with us
they forgive us
they're still proud of having served
with americans they still believed in
the future that we were all fighting for
them in their country and they still
believed that their service was
worthwhile and they would have done it
all over again if given the opportunity
those types of people are absolutely
worth saving we should be moving heaven
and earth to get them
your organization no one left behind you
have helped evacuate afghans over the
years with these special visas
what can you do what can your
organization do are you even able to do
anything
right now there is
a army of people
folks from no one left behind from the
association of wartime allies from
all sorts of different organizations and
we're all now fighting to do one thing
mount the largest airlift
ever probably in the history of
humankind what about the administration
do you think president biden will go
along with that he's the
commander-in-chief
i hope so
you know the indication from the defense
department seems to be that at least
they're committed to kabul our goal is
now we as we've said we have a beachhead
we need to keep that beach head open for
as long as we possibly can to get as
many people as we possibly can out with
whatever time we have left remaining
that time frame should not be dictated
to us by
the taliban i i know that people might
hate this but sometimes human rights
have to be defended at the barrel end of
a gun there are really truly evil people
in this world i am not being hyperbolic
when i say that the taliban are the
modern day equivalent of the nazi party
when afghanistan city after city started
to fall last week did you think we would
get to the point where kabul was overrun
by the weekend
yes
what we did not expect was the complete
and total capitulation
of the ghani government and a seemingly
uh you know they handed kabul over
without almost firing a shot an islamic
insurgency just overthrew their
democratically elected government and
let's be clear about this they're now
one of the largest military powers in
central asia
they they have a fully functioning air
force because they inherited the afghan
military so all of our u.s military
equipment all the humvees the mraps all
the m4s machine guns the armed freaking
drones they have it all this is not the
taliban in the 90s this is taliban 2.0
and that scares
that scares the daylights out of me
because
what happens when al qaeda 2.0 decides
to finally make afghanistan its new
headquarters
so that's of course a big fear
there have been
critics of the president who said we
should have left a small force we
already had a small force
that would help to prevent what happened
in the collapse of the government if we
left a couple thousand troops do you
think we would be in the situation today
we are in
no if we had done this in an orderly way
if we had set up and indicated to the
taliban that no we're going to maintain
a robust you know counter-terrorism
presence that is going to be able to
bomb you to smithereens that this this
withdrawal yeah the trump administration
might have said it's the first of may
but congratulations you're not a
legitimate government i don't understand
why we continue to negotiate with people
who have no right to rule
who elected them no one
we shouldn't have been negotiating them
in good faith to begin with we should
have been telling them we're going to
leave when we feel like it
but that that entirely is on the trump
administration not the biden
administration donald trump and mike
pompeo are as just as guilty and is just
as complacent in the deaths that are
about to befall our afghan allies as the
taliban they made this deal it's on them
for now having it put us into this mess
i still however and i'm saying this to
you as a proud democrat blame my party
and this is where i wish the republicans
in this country would learn from this
example i blame my party i'm going to
hold my president accountable i'm going
to call for public hearings held by
congress to get to the bottom of this i
hope it's my party that investigates
this because that's what responsible
leadership looks like and that's what
we've got to get back to in this country
if you care about american soldiers
coming home from future wars like i did
well the only reason i'm talking today
is because an afghan saved my life in a
battle i made him a promise that we
would honor that life debt we now need
to keep that promise for the over 100
000 afghans that remain left behind
the one who saved your life
is he
out of the country yeah yeah he's out of
the country i was able to get him out
eight years ago
and now
you're hoping that the rest of them can
come too
i am
i'm not an overtly religious person
but i haven't prayed more in my life
all i want is for us to save these
people
i know we can do it i know we have the
resources to do it i know we have the
might to do it
i pray that we find the will
matt zeller former u.s army major xcia
analyst co-founder of no one left behind
thank you so much for joining us my
pleasure talk soon
[Music]
this is liz peek with your fox news
commentary coming up
july saw a record high number of migrant
apprehensions the u.s mexico border more
than 212 thousand and president biden's
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayarkas said during a recent visit with
agents in texas that it was
unprecedented the rise in encounters of
migrants at the southern border began in
april of 2020 last year but the increase
is most certainly sharper over the past
several months and greater than in june
privately though my orcas took a
straightforward tone with agents in
audio obtained by fox news reporter bill
mollusian out of texas last week this is
unsustainable
these numbers cannot continue
case that was hard to hear he said this
is unsustainable these numbers cannot
continue he also told the agents that if
the border is our first line of defense
then we are going to lose meanwhile he
says most adult migrants are being
turned away under title 42 a public
health authorization due to covid
unaccompanied minors though are not
being expelled under title 42. yeah i
think it's a really astonishing comments
these comments were behind closed doors
to dhs officials law enforcement
officials chadwolf is former acting
homeland security secretary and a
current heritage foundation visiting
fellow it's very different than the
message that he's telling the american
people and to members of congress as he
testifies where he says the border is
closed the border is secure
we have this under control
and then he's telling his law
enforcement officers
who actually are working on the border
so they know the difference they know
that that the border is not open and the
border is not secure
and so he's trying to connect with them
and and reassure them that
he knows what they're going through but
in in doing so he has
demonstrated that he's he's got two sets
of talking points one for the american
public in congress and then one for
uh all the officials at dhs so
it's it's quite startling i i made sure
that you know as acting secretary when i
was there that it was the same message
whether it was to dhs officials and law
enforcement officers or to the american
people
and that is what the american people are
so frustrated at is the crisis that's on
the border today is that this
administration is not being upfront with
them they're not telling the truth about
what's going on well if the truth is
that this is unsustainable and we are
going to lose whatever that means
what what happens now and
does what happens
next
sort of depend because it sound it looks
like secretary mark marcus is maybe
between a rock and a hard place between
what his boss the president maybe wants
border policy to look like versus what
he
knows it looks like and what he finds to
be unsustainable like what does he do
with these
two competing things
well sure but that's his job it's a
difficult job is to uh talk to white
house officials whether that's the
president the vice president or others
and let them know what his department is
capable of doing along that border and
what's achievable and what's not
and so again when you have these
comments and you hear that it's it's not
winnable i think that what what it tells
you is that the failed border security
strategy that we've seen over the last
seven months is just that it's it's
failed
they need a new strategy they need a new
approach to turn this crisis around
because if they continue to do what
they're been doing for six seven six and
a half seven months now
uh you're just gonna have more of the
same so hopefully the comments were a
turning point i don't suspect
uh that policy will change although i
can be hopeful uh but the policy needs
to change uh to really address this
crisis because everything that they
continue to do
doesn't really make a dent in the crisis
it gets worse month after month after
month i want your reaction to outgoing
border patrol chief rodney scott's
comments um i guess his recording of him
was obtained by the washington examiner
and he was telling fellow agents that
when they talk about what their mission
is and this is a quote from him i firmly
believe that it is a national security
crisis immigration is just a
sub-component of it and right now it's
just a cover for massive amounts of
smuggling
to include tsdbs at a level we've never
seen before tsdb's terrorist screening
database alerts um so in other words
suspected terrorists he's saying
that folks like that are coming at a
level we've never seen before what he is
saying there is is what we've known all
along and it really uh you know i would
implore congress and others to really
investigate
what the premise of what he is saying
there which is
it's not only do you have
you know family members you have
families and minors and others coming
across this border but you have a
criminal element and you have a national
security element there such as suspected
terrorists coming across that border
and the administration in the department
hasn't been very
honest with the american people and
really outlining that you can do that in
a way where you
you you can talk around classified
information but if there are really
suspected terrorists who are embedding
themselves with this this flow and we
know that either by
intelligence or we've apprehended them i
think that's something that the american
people need to understand that this
isn't just immigration this is about
drugs this is about cartel activity and
this is about national security now
former chief patrol agent roy villarreal
retired just about eight months ago and
he says the border is not just an
opportunity for economic migrants but a
myriad of criminal elements in the 30
31 years almost 32 years of border
security that i provided
there's only one of the time that i saw
the border this vulnerable and it was
back in the late 80s but the threat was
very different um
the threat was more it was these were
economic migrants and it was just a
volume of people that were coming across
the border
that threat compared to today's threat
but do not equate to one another today
we are faced with
a border system that is overwhelmed by
family units and unaccompanied children
which
has drawn away agents from their focus
on border security because now they're
in the business of caring
and looking after these migrants
and what that has done is created
tremendous gaps and vulnerabilities and
these are going to be exploited not that
i mean they're exploited today by the
criminal organizations
but i assure you terrorists are looking
for the same opportunities and they will
exploit them
when you heard scott's comments that
there is this increase in tsdbs
terrorist screening database alerts
is is that accurate
one of the things we have to take in
consideration is that the us border
patrol encounters people from throughout
the world
from venezuela all the way to
afghanistan
and uh in in that mix of people that are
encountered you do find people that are
either associated affiliated or in some
manner may be related to terrorists
terrorism excuse me are they coming like
do they get an airplane ticket and fly
from
you know jordan
to
uh i don't know argentina i mean how
does this work
smuggling in and of itself is a
multi-billion dollar industry that
traverses the entire globe
and as it relates to
um hardcore criminals special interest
aliens
those associated affiliated with
terrorism there are very sophisticated
criminal networks that cater to this
type of client
and there are established routes that
are utilized
that uh traverse the globe um and in
some cases they're coming
literally they're flying uh straight
into mexico and right to our border
um
i wanna shift gears how i wanna talk
about covet how bad
is it i imagine you still speak to to
folks um
on the border uh your friends i'm i'm
wondering even though you're retired how
bad is the covid situation because we're
hearing you know the the president
himself has said we're you know we're
still operating under title 42 right
we're still expelling migrants not all
of them but many of them
um due to covid
and
and yet
city officials in mcallen texas opening
up you know quarantine centers for
migrants with covid what are agents
dealing with when it comes to this
infectious disease
the dangers that the agents face at the
border in and of itself from narcotics
smugglers to weapons traffickers to just
violent criminals is one thing in and of
itself but now we've introduced covid
and in the last
year and a half two years
a number of agents as well as a number
of
officers at the ports of entry have been
exposed have contracted covet and have
died as a result of it so copa is a
reality that that the agents face every
day and it just
complicates and amplifies the dangers
that they face
and
when you talk about being overwhelmed
let's talk about those july numbers
right because that was apparently
a record for um
apprehensions over 200 000 in in one
month alone i'm used to hearing as a
southern california native i'm used to
hearing about sort of a um a downtick in
people coming in the summer because it's
so hot um we're not we're not seeing
that trend this year
traditionally um there's normally a
downtick beginning in early summer
all the way up through october
that has ebbed over the last few years
but the border as it sits today and this
is based on my 30 years of working in
border security is the most vulnerable
it's been in two decades
the flow of illegal migration the volume
and the type of population that's coming
across the border is simply overwhelming
the capabilities and the capacity of
the border patrol
of ero of ice the department of homeland
security as a whole
and it's it's unprecedented it's created
a tremendous
weakness
and opportunity
for criminals and terrorists to exploit
finally when you heard secretary
mallorca say privately to agents in
texas that this flow is unsustainable
and that if the border is our first line
of defense then we are going to lose
what did you think and did it give you
any
hope i guess for lack of a better word
that dhs sees the problem clearly for
what it is
we need to acknowledge and accept that
border security equates to national
security and the fact that the secretary
of homeland security is acknowledging
that this is unsustainable
is it encouraging slightly but the
reality is is the effort and the focus
that's been applied towards border
security thus far
has been an utter failure
the administration is
it's innovative in its approach it's
it's hoping to reach back into the host
countries but that investment takes time
that investment is a decade or two
decades from now we need a focus that
addresses border security today while
simultaneously addressing those those
other aspects but do i have a sense of
of hope or encouragement based on the
fact that the secretary acknowledged
that this is unsustainable absolutely
not there's been an awareness of the
situation at the border for months now
and prior to the administration assuming
um
it's it's rain they are briefed on the
threats they are briefed on our
understanding of what was happening
south
of the border and throughout the globe
so their awareness was on par day one
and this is just simply another failure
to address that
former chief patrol agent roy villarreal
thank you so much for your time
absolutely thank you i appreciate the
opportunity
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
peak
what's on your mind americans are
wondering is joe biden up to the job
among the alarming developments of the
past week for team biden was reports
showing that consumer sentiment
absolutely collapsed in early august the
index plunged to 70.2 from 81.2 the
month before posting one of the biggest
drops on record and reaching the worst
level since 2011.
that spells trouble for the economy and
for biden
why are consumers suddenly unhappy
let me count the ways
first the pandemic is back in force
just as americans began to hope that
vaccines would lead us back to normalcy
the delta variant has roared through the
nation
jeopardizing our recovery summer and
crushing optimism
the coveted 19 case count soared to 214
000 on august 13th
from just under 7 000 two months ago
worse hospitalizations and deaths have
turned up as well
team biden politicized the entire
vaccination effort blaming republicans
for the disappointing uptake on the
shots
the reality is that many americans and
especially many in the black community
are wary of the medication in part
because the fda has yet to approve it it
turns out politicizing copen 19 was a
stupid thing to do it will haunt biden
next prices on just about everything we
buy are going up and again the white
house has not helped
after repeating endlessly that price
hikes would be transitory the
administration pivoted to different
language but the same message
inflation was the result of temporary
blockages and would quickly disappear
americans don't buy it a recent report
from the new york federal reserve showed
consumers expect prices to continue
rising over the next three years
that's bad news because consumer
expectations actually can drive
inflation
meanwhile our nation is suffering
humiliation in afghanistan and that
country faces unimaginable tragedy
biden called for an immediate withdrawal
of u.s forces from that sad nation
and the consequences already are so
horrific that he is now sending in
thousands of troops to secure the safety
of our own people
when cnn's jake tapper opens his
interview with secretary of state
anthony blinken asking how did president
biden get this so wrong you know the
white house is in trouble
finally more than 1 million people have
been detained over the past 12 months
crossing our southern border illegally
this past week homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas was caught
on tape admitting to border control
agents that the situation is quote
unsustainable unquote and that the
system recently came close to breaking
this is unconscionable and it is biden's
fault for rescinding trump policies that
had stemmed the flood of migrants the
president has from day one brought a
wrecking ball to every single policy
enacted by donald trump whether or not
those measures were successful
biden considers his greatest virtue that
he is not trump he is correct
polling shows that more people voted
against trump than for biden
we are discovering that not being trump
is not good enough
biden is failing and he has only himself
to blame
i'm liz peek fox news
contributor you've been listening to the
fox news rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes